when I do something silly if I do
succeed the gains will then be
disproportionate
[Music]
keeping with the laws of physics and
Hayek made this point it's kind of what
economics has tried to do and totally
failed to do I think is to create the
same kind of certainties around
predictive models of human behavior that
exist in the physical sciences and you
can do that of course because the laws
of physics don't change you know what
you know what's true about gravity in
three years time is pretty much what was
true 200 years ago and so in building
space shuttles and aircraft and so forth
that entirely rational numerical
approach works now the first problem you
have with human behavior is there aren't
metrics for most of the things we care
about you know we don't have SI units
for regret irritation Injustice
Etc and so
this attempt I think by economists to
create a kind of physics of human
behavior was pretty much doomed from the
very beginning but it's also true
because a the future is you know
fashioned very simply okay you know what
is good today is not necessarily liked
tomorrow people's taste change people's
preferences change people's priorities
change and therefore you have this
fundamental problem that if you if
you're always dealing with big data or
past data you're over optimized on the
past effectively
and I think you know that that's another
serious problem about uh um you know all
big data comes from the same place the
past and therefore it's fundamentally
unrepresentative of what possible
Futures could be
and in in an economy we we also assume
or in the past it was assumed that human
behavior is very rational and
predictable and that's not quite how
humans are
and uh would you like to
no that's right I mean as I was saying
so
that that's the absolutely fascinating
thing about any attempt creates the
perfect model of human behavior that as
I said about the the kind of girdling
completeness and notion that you know we
we are the sort of Gap in any perfect
system in a sense it's always going to
be the unpredictable quality but I was
thinking as well is that also that idea
that and I I realize that that's that's
the thing that subjectivity represents
but I was also I'm really interested in
this question I think it's the sort of
Hamlet Paradox when Rory was talking as
well that that you have this idea of
someone actually the tragedy that you
often see in in works of literature is
that someone's trying their best to do
what they believe to be the right thing
and everything works around them to
shift the terms of the reality and
that's kind of also what's happening to
us when we try to navigate shifting
realities online and everything kind of
changes and we're not quite sure of the
rules of the game that we're being
induced to play and you can see that
with Hamlet that he gets the message
from the ghost you know I'm your dead
dad go and kill your uncle and he's
constantly trying to reason with this
actually really unreasonable set of
circumstances which is that he's in a
Revenge tragedy and he's got to just
kill everyone but he's trying to make
rational decisions and I think we really
have that online that there's a kind of
strange digital Paradox that's going on
where something's happening that we
don't quite understand the loss of the
time we're being denied the ultimate
rationality with sort of being a bit
maneuvered and that brings in really
interesting questions I think in terms
of Enlightenment Notions of the rational
autonomous women who can make decisions
based on knowing everything in fact at
the moment with this kind of
misinformation Rising uncertainty of the
real and unreal actors I think you're
getting a situation where even if you're
trying your utmost like Hamlet you can't
quite gather all the information you
need there's a massive strange process
that's occluding certain things for
various reasons so I think that's
something it's kind of like we we're
living in a novel without really wanting
to live in a novel it's that sort of odd
thing
and so you know looking on to the Future
how can we
fix this situation you mentioned that
animals don't need rationalism
rationality to survive so I mean there
are funny cases in the animal kingdom
actually where uh because of interaction
between different animals it pays you to
be irrational now one you know one of
them would be doing the unexpected thing
okay if it is irrational for you to
fight back if attacked by a superior
Force but actually uh it may be
necessary because otherwise if you're
completely rational in terms of where
you fight and where you flee uh you'll
just get taken advantage of it's the
unpredictable possibility that you may
turn disproportionately nasty that keeps
you safe for example there's a wonderful
um Anthropologist called Jesse Behrens
who says I'm a complete atheist but when
I get into a taxi in a foreign country I
always like to see a few religious icons
hanging from the rear view mirror I
don't believe them the guy upstairs but
I like to know that my driver believes
there's someone watching him you see
um which he do and there's an awful lot
of games here there's a fascinating
thing about hairs which is when they're
chased by a dog if you've ever seen it
I'm sorry I don't even think I go hair
coursing but if you've seen it on
YouTube okay just to be clear
um the hair will basically just leap
around at random suddenly jump in the
air then it'll take a violent left the
hair actually has no control over this
the brain enters apparently a kind of
random number generator
and the head doesn't even know itself
what it's going to be doing and the
reason for that is if the hair didn't
know
it would give away telltale signs that
it was about to turn left dogs would
have evolved the facility to read these
signs and the hairs wouldn't Escape so
there are certain cases where actually
behaving at random is actually rational
for example and so that that's that all
of this stuff arises and the other one I
was mentioning sort of advertising and
marketing I always consider consumer
capitalism as kind of even if you don't
like it okay it's the kind of Galapagos
Islands of human behavior okay and the
fact that of course one of the dangers
of being rational is that you tend to
end up in the same place as all your
competitors
and the thing that I continually noticed
with really successful businesses is
they contain an element of complete
absurdity so you know before Dyson
brought out his vacuum cleaner there was
no rational argument for believing there
was a market for an 800 pound back
okay I could have given you 15 reasons
why I was drafted and I would say if
you'd given a lot of rational people the
job of coming up with a competitive
Coca-Cola they would have said well we
need a really nice dating drink that
cost less than Coke and comes in a
really big container but the biggest
success in competing with Coke is Red
Bull which cost a fortune comes with a
tiny Cannon tastes disgusting okay so so
there is of course it's worth noting
that if life is to some extended Game of
Poker there is this question of do I do
what's sensible which everybody else
does or actually when I do something
silly if I do succeed the gains will
then be disproportionate so you know and
deciding between those two is is not
something I think you can make
rationally in a way
yeah I mean what you're saying it sort
of reminds me of
Thomas Coons
Inception of how science works that it
proceeds by
um Revolution
um so you know there's this idea that
sort of science is just sort of
completely Guided by reason but of
course you get these uh these
these occurrences in science where sort
of everybody will be adhering to you
know what what would call look at
the Paradigm so that a set of
assumptions that sort of grounds
discoveries and then over time you'll
sort of discover problems or sort of
things that can't be explained and then
there'll be a revolution which is kind
of like let's just reject all the
foundational assumptions we were
starting with and and replace it with
something else so you know example might
be the replacement of Newtonian
mechanics with it's the quantum world
view so the idea is that I mean that's
not rational that's because the sort of
rational part of that is what what's you
know what he calls normal science when
you're sort of working within the sort
of non-revolutionary part where you'll
just sort of deriving new discoveries
from these sort of foundational
assumptions which takes you so far but
you know it doesn't describe the world
perfectly and then when you realize you
you kind of you've that there's things
that you really can't explain anymore
then you have to kind of just Chuck
everything out and sort of get a new set
of assumptions and I think think you
know sort of what you're saying that
reminds me of that where you've got this
sort of period of time so you know sort
of coke is sort of okay based on what we
know what is the next logical step and
then occasionally there'll be sort of
something happening that comes out of
left field and that's you know that's
not logic that's the sort of creative a
new a new idea that doesn't come from
logic but then that sort of demonstrates
the limitations or someone simply note I
mean an awful lot of Discovery is not
intentional it's scientists noticing
something
um penicillin being the most famous
example the microwave oven came out of a
um a scientist working on radiation uh
something called radiation who noticed
that the chocolate bar his pocket kept
melting okay and I always love the story
from business which is the walls
viennetta
um came about because there was a faulty
conveyor belt in the factory which
caused what should have been a flat slab
of ice cream to come out of the shape of
scroll work and again it was an act of
observation hey that looks great you
know and actually I'm not sure you'd get
there intentionally ever you know I'm
not sure it's something I'm not sure
it's a request stop you know it's what
so much of this stuff is actually
someone with the right mindset simply
observing happy accents or whatever it
may be and you you can't really
attribute those successes to reason can
you yes you're in the whole thing of
serendipity you know
you know walk around now and we're kind
of kind of guided you know by our Google
device and so on but that I was thinking
of all the encounters everyone had
through total Serendipity do you
remember and you sort of go out and you
just meet a series of people and you'd
end up sort of you know married to one
of them just by these random sort of
sequences that would happen so that
thing as well I think as well as you
were talking about science
um there's a short story by broadcast
called exactitude in science and it's
it's decided that the scientists of this
great Empire wanted to make these maps
that corresponded completely to the
reality totally point-to-point in every
element and so in the end they had to
create these maps that were as big as
the reality they're enormous you know
massive
reality-sized pieces of paper and of
course they couldn't work at all as Maps
you know you just got in the way and no
one could live in their houses and so
they had to just abandon them so that
idea that if you push a rational idea to
a really really extraordinary extreme
you end up with quite the opposite of
what you wanted and actually on you know
we all have predictive Tech as well and
I don't know what's going on with that
because it predicts the most totally
Preposterous thing I mean well this
isn't Preposterous actually the other
day I was trying to type in fiction and
it my phone predicted it as big ruin
which I thought okay that what is what
is the phone trying to tell me but this
sort of why has you know
why has anyone ever put that in and the
notion of who what is the algorithm that
predicts the most Preposterous and
unpredictable things that we're about to
type what's going on there I also think
there's a danger which is when we obsess
about what you might call the
intentionality of progress is we only
measure in the positive column those
things that our idea achieves that were
intended beforehand because quite a lot
of you know quite a lot of interesting
ideas have unintended consequences which
is sometimes very very negative but
they're sometimes very very positive so
I mean your example of serendipity in
meeting I always joke when I had teenage
daughters what my daughters did not have
Okay was a party strategy okay basically
all they knew was that when you go to
parties you increase your this is sort
of the same Talib talk you increase your
surface area exposure to positive upside
optionality you see okay now you don't
know you do it's completely fallacious
to go to a party with an intention of
what the value you're going to derive is
from that party all you know is that if
you never go to a party you never get
lucky effectively okay and what that
luck could be you don't actually Define
in advance you simply go the the reason
it's worthwhile doing this thing is
because might happen that I never
anticipated that I subsequently come to
value and so that worries me about a lot
of business planning I think there is
scope for just saying we're going to try
two or three random things to see what
the outcome is and it's very difficult
to do because the finance people it's
much much easier to quantify costs than
it is to quantify an opportunity cost
and so that very sort of accounts-driven
Finance driven approach to activity
effectively just leads to cost cutting
as a default Behavior
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas